hello everyone thank you very much for
joining us at Simeon's second annual
virtual symposium advances in drug
discovery and development I'm Kevin
Davis the publisher of senior and I'm
very happy to introduce our next speaker
Enoch Wang who is executive director of
computational Sciences at pfizer Enochs
talk will be entitled of soft drinks and
software and very much looking forward
to his presentation having heard him
speak many times during my years as
editor-in-chief of bio IT world Enoch is
a leader in the computational biology
and computational sciences world in Big
Pharma following Enochs talk i'll come
back to ask a few questions this is a
pre-recorded presentation due to enochs
schedule so there won't be the
opportunity for live Q&A but I'll ask
some questions at the end of Enochs
presentation a quick reminder seen yen
as always does not endorse any
particular company or product or
services that you may hear mentioned in
any of the talks the talk will be
archived on demand for several months
after the conference so you have a
chance to to share with colleagues I've
been unable to tune in on the day of the
actual broadcast so without further ado
it's my great pleasure to welcome you
know Quang you knock over to you and
good morning everyone like to start my
talk by posing a question for the
audience cleaners have you ever wondered
why softer and attentive here and for
all the hounds cans or 14 ounce bottles
call your connivance this deep mystery
for me interesting for people in my life
so this is my nephew and niece one hot
summer day they decided settle a
beverage then outside at home if they
had created an original custom made
refreshing move your float and you have
to live in the neighborhood passing by
they were first and and you may need to
have a really clear float figure means
like the net they sold out every single
one of their floats and according to my
sister-in-law they turn a tidy profit as
well I found out about their little
business venture because I saw a posting
on Facebook and even had they known that
was in the mood for a root beer float
there's no way for them to package up
that product in distributed to me this
turns out to be a classic London for any
inventor or product of a platform for
solution which is how do you distribute
it father customers no matter where they
are not because my nephew and niece did
not have access to one of these
industrial scale bottling plant nor one
of these of need of trucks going to take
the product the garbage once it's been
bottled stacking these trays to the
point of sale which is for these many
machines around the world of course
separate we signal from this money so my
point is that a little bit of
standardization goes a long way because
once the greed upon the size and shape
of the bottle they can take advantage of
all the superstructure in fact the
bottle doesn't care ingredients of the
beverage that is holding the beverage
itself doesn't know we need to know
where it's being delivered and all the
consumer needs to know is where the
nearest vending machine is and how to
use it so the answer to my question is
that you have a trick you have a
situation product and you follow certain
standards is no need to rebuild
infrastructure or deliver your product
so much for soft drinks what does that
have to do with software on this case
scientific software it turns out we
follow very single out advisor around a
molecular design convinces them at the
heart of this ecosystem is a
computational services for over which
across ECT this broker provides
essentially bottomley distribution to
the point of sale of our products in
this case is a computational method for
algorithms that can invent it anywhere
to the consumer and medicinal chemists
at the vending machine
design fools that are already music as
far as these tools concerned their
combination vendors of five schools I
came from sixteen pipeline pilot in
Spotfire and as well in cows
applications that are from design for
physics past so move it for community
design idea for hybrid design keep a
community design and analysis this is
possible because like the soft soft
drink industry we have chosen an defied
very carefully few standards like the
sides and shake the bottle but
importantly not what was inside the
bottle in other words standardization is
not the level of how these components
are written it exists more than one way
to solve human problems standardizations
at the level of the architecture how to
confirm for your actions each other so
we can achieve in is a system that
allows new computational solutions
methods plugin in existing design
applications even social services
importantly supports diversity
imitations the code is different between
the pool or method in pumpkin and the
application workhouses it for example
and move it who write that in C++ and
keypad in Java and provender cluelessly
on taxes or stove itself the
computational methods and tools can be
written in whatever language so the code
there's book the code base is not shared
and encode actually runs on the server
so paradoxically the solution is classic
problem how do you sustain computational
innovations through the application of
standards is ironic that something as
wild and insane as computational
innovation can be and be unleashed by
something mundane of standards and the
physics on the following standards where
it makes sense so I'm going to zoom in
on just a couple design applications in
more detail one being a move it there
safe for 3d design and Kiki opportunity
design well first let's take a look
closer look at the volume plan itself
this is the CCP service process there's
a publisher application which
essentially is where the complications
graph into the CCP framework for
downstream consumption typically a CCP
service itself is a script set of
instructions could be a shell script or
Python script something like that that
has certainly inputs and outputs which
are defined the file phone was defined
and if there are any parameters we also
both ends in as well once it's been
wrapped into ztt then this protocol for
all the description appears fine sigh on
the on the design application in this
case move it so by following this
process what's preserved is a metadata
about the method itself you can see in
the protocol tree in this case and move
it a series of different tools which are
in publishing you to decide which tools
North appropriate for the task at hand
and you can see that the description of
the algorithm not a method who wrote it
links to documentation and so forth so
there are many benefits that have a
system like cct behind the scenes
stitching together innovation and
applications the first to the software
developer of the application first is
that new functionality can be plugged in
played into the system without changing
the code base itself define application
keeps the kind applications fresh and
relevant you can harness these new
functionalities which can be to help
wherever novel functionality that
carefully tested simply x
instantaneously appeared in the
applications in a way that makes the
application very easy for valve m18
secondly cct services handles execution
itself on the server side that means if
there are a specific requirement for
what kind of platform the method runs on
Neville info windows if there are
licensing considerations tokens are
handling kind of scenes based on the
matron size of the job CeCe keep inside
is there a machine that i can lend us on
immediately or is it too big we want to
meet with me on a single machine we need
to farm this out the batch it up and
running on the power grid if you look
cute and you will see now we have
cloud option as well appear the inventor
or creator of improvisational fools are
many benefits probably most important is
that ccp supports many different
programming languages so the creator of
the fool can use whatever is most
familiar taking of her that fosters
innovation also the creator of the fool
can have a piece of mind that only once
written for the results are presented
from consistent way in the multitude of
different interfaces that also have the
benefit view more customers chemists in
a variety of places hook through graphic
faces Royals applications and platforms
very important is that we have
production support with a capital P
where it makes sense that where it also
stays out the way or it doesn't make
sense what don't mean what is what I
mean is that ctt has production support
hierarchy beef which means that a
framework for self is guaranteed to have
support and maintenance and the hardware
necessary run the drafts also on a
support contract with IT but the
inventor big fool does not had to follow
a former formal software abundant life
cycle he or she can published new
methods as they come into the system the
frame of kinky and design applications
for their surrogate providing
responsibility by teasers for is
responsible for effort for the frame of
acct the machines that that run it the
science is responsible to quality agri
to the method and finally if the method
itself is computationally intense they
offer worry about whether it be the
client can can handle it because atc
amazon will be that heavy looking for
their multiple benefits of consumer as
well first is that the design chemist
who just use whatever tools and
applications that they're already
familiar with probably chosen to go to
the fastest can you don't have to learn
a new system every time a new
computational method available so using
these fools in that context here you can
select protein-ligand adams preparing
the job the mission you push a button
and then ccp then runs in
both back in the context often within
the same visualization frame for jobs
mission so the consumer of the premise
that even though the CCP's their
innocence ECT facilitates the concept of
crowdsourcing you can harness the
innovation irrespective gate-source we
have full 180 ctp but from academic
groups from software vendors and from
in-house developers but this prevents us
from having happening is following a
trap of non event here for vendor one
very important for the computational
chemist in particular if that valuable
time is not spent on data munging no one
ever went to a page tu a postdoc and
computational chemistry so so they can
spend all the time messing around with
file format grinding parsers running in
keene calculations and fill awaiting the
results in yourself potential tennis
instead they should be spending time in
preventing methods and applying them to
drug discovery projects so cct was
originally conceived as a global
property calculation engine so very
standard parameters that people want to
know about the compound beating before
they made them but not surprising the
most popular popular calculations are
such a tease for Cairo bonds Hydra bond
donors except turns zone on so forth
also very frequently access of structure
based filters sister structure alerts
that might raise flags as potential
toxicity of the molecule more recently
we now train a series of global Adlene
Cox models based on our standard set of
battery of assays that we run company
for solubility permeability Ravi and
urbanization so ctt was the introduction
about a decade ago and you can see from
this graph steadily flown over this
decade now there was a blip where usage
seemed to fall before recovering finding
a new photo what's happening here is
that this is for instance with resizing
rd organization including which include
a new personal chemistry but the rebound
tells us that now CCGs leaving work
places more applications than ever
before and by a higher percentage
for medicinal chemistry or organization
also recent years we put in place a set
of automated data falls from nightly CTT
access to the latest round of project
data ready for them to project team the
next one what was boiled down to is that
there are a hundred of there there's a
million requests being processed by cct
enter them running 800 million compounds
every month that visor cool progression
is a pretty impressive achievement I
just want to highlight one way see
feeder acts with commercial applications
in this case Python pilot cct protocols
to be wrapped as pipe on college
components look carefully here this is a
structure alerts the affair that appears
as a rigid which we strung together in a
pipeline pilot protocol entire protocols
can also be invoked by cct applications
applications of our CCP wherein can run
these are compiling job CT CT we switch
gears and talk about its conflict with
regeneration Lee transformation which is
using computers that have prior
knowledge to generate new design ideas
this is different from as computer
computer to fifth what happened to make
up specific chemical modification in
this case the chemists already has a
design objective mountain biking to a
particular attribute while keeping areas
and confident but having a computer
suggest ideas that have come a far more
likely to conscious level so this slide
might seem a little odd in terms of it
looking feel and that's because several
years ago at helping move from
management control key to build a slide
explain this concept of senior
management they got it therefore for you
it was look at the slide have an input
molecule could be rendered in 2d or 3d
there's a part of molecule that you on
your substituent and having having
system suggest alternatives that can
achieve this design objective the way
that works there's a series of
algorithms that will search the
available chemicals Facebook fragments
that can substitute it could be based on
tacit knowledge from
put in such a way that comparison we've
been over it for example the
substitution of Petra's all for Carver
silicic acid if you've been following
the rules of energetics calculating what
a fit and make fable interactions or
statistics lesson substituted successful
for or complement to specific enrolled
in on geometry shape but what while
these fragments are being substituted
then collated and thinking to me to
output of new structures which then are
filled different ranked based on the
design objective be novelty add the
property of the optimized code to see
whatever behind the scenes of course our
algorithm for for searching and storing
the databases for bio Isis years of
prison structures of happy and then what
reappears in my application are these
prioritize ideas in the context of what
it's already been submitted in community
for cutie so that's the basic idea and
terms of pfizer we didn't serve a few
years ago the scene with an American
riches of these so funny translation
rules each specializing different areas
some are are specializing in facing the
core of a molecule others diversity for
others both there are those that work
for me on 2d formats so there's 3d and
still others in both social visit the
side through the CCP protocol tree which
one solves a problem that you had a hand
access Oki walk through a big example i
mentioned that ccp protocols of this
type this interdesign applications this
is a 3d with not application for move it
within the movement window one can then
access the right menu and select ligand
idea generator or we've seen here is for
me that one is trying to optimize sub
substitutions of the core so here you
see the protocol tree here is now a good
application with different ccp4 idea
generation that work in 3d and metadata
about the protocol here's see the most
scaffold placement
you can cause you a little about the
method and databases which will access
and Orpheus is the one you want to do
and the job gets prepared for cct
submission here you're selecting the
molecule and specific atoms that you
want some of which you want to keep the
others like you want to substitute
interactively will then move it for the
job of run you can see the steam set up
red sniffles we look carefully this
piece which will be observed and then
yellow founds the core that you're
trying to subject see things are a bit
cheerier design objective so now the
results are coming back from CT t going
to visit in the same reference frames of
here the query here's the first result
of these back you can also calculate top
games upon these both compound with now
the courts and substituted conceived in
the periphery is things saying not a
potential solution final one this all
happens sent you instantaneously from
the cruel interactive invisible fence
you push a button just see all the
summarized itself in a table format the
compound will come back line in such a
way with properties of your side which
ones seem to achieve that design
objective gold synthesis festival so
that's how cct interacts with the
methods that have been wrapped with the
cct the other ways can design compounds
the generate ideas around how to
optimize their property not by examining
the specific compounds the ligands and
fragments but by using the binding site
yourself in this case the query is
actually a part of the poking that
interacts with a fragment that you want
to modify CCP pigs the binding site the
protein and representative the shape
then decorates the shape with different
colors and its face hydrogen bond donors
except tears and charges and this
colored shape becomes a query of a set
of pre computed pockets that interactive
ligands see what other finding pockets
are similar in terms of the shape for
the status this is implemented with the
overnight toolkit here's an example of a
kinase inhibitor here's a pyridine ring
that we're looking to substitute and
this particular pocket becomes that
queries which I refer to that pocket
then you can search a database of other
binding sites and we've returned are
these fragments which are bound by top
of similar to the quarry pockets and
stitch together for the rest of the
model tool that you might expect for the
kinase inhibitor the other fragments
which come from kind of programs but
occasionally you will also see those
coming back from gene families that are
unrelated to each requiring that perhaps
we'll leave the chemistry and the
five-team a very interesting pack very
popular in the 3d design world is ways
of cuddly aligning or relaying liggins
we important different for number two
voice through this human to hear first
if you have two interpreters that he
wanted will delay line we use oh meghan
rocks with our overnight fools to align
in this case the orange knowledge with
the reference model for which is green
so make it easy to generate different
reading confirmation of rocks performed
the overlay this is our run
interactively if you have a common sub
structure you can get directly super
impose those until goes off and then but
the best can please align the rest of
the molecule having go before to
complain one thing about chemists I find
to be truly pragmatic and oftentimes
they want to know about certain
reluctant interaction has been
successfully me before and if so exactly
how it looks in 3d so we want to
facilitate this kind of searching for
global constructor database so we
provide interface and move it that you
can specify what types of criteria that
looking for on the ligand side and
cooking sides of manuel CT goes off in
search of database and retrieve the fitz
highlighting the different atoms which
nationally query
accordingly now there are a number of
examples for you my apologies for
instance show show me all the mean or
arrow keys that form hydrogen bonds of
carpet silk asset side chain or show me
all the climbing looking for form water
medium mediated hydrogen bonds depend
recipes for the example shown here to
show me all the stacking interactions
between argentina side chains and biomat
acquaintance a few years ago I was
involved in research project that softer
come up with a method to forgive the
drug ability of a target based on this
structure by my side this is a big team
effort i'm very pleased that is
published a few years ago what because
there but spices say that given a
binding site create an internal
structure divine insight be the scored
with two key parameters first in 2%
hydrophobic well fifth to the higher
binding site and the others the
curvature the binding site the idea
being equally curved when most
incredible funny sight smell lovely
support high affinity binding of ligand
little drug like saucepan from the
referee over so at the time after we
wrote a series of applications egypt
that we distributed executables in a tar
file to anyone running a boat warn them
that finding key piece of software it is
no unit future interface who actually
suggested was hoping cells a local
expert who was trained in running this
application to fight it that was several
years ago now the advent of ccp we can
now publish the fight of algorithm move
it a three-dimensional design
application so that anyone completely
feminism Emma scan success by the target
and the Ligon if the profile substrate
if we find the binding site which a
button and that what return is back and
move it for the final results draw
bilities for the maximum achievable
theoretical binding energy surface area
characteristics in polar nonpolar terms
and the curvature and we provide
visualization to fans of how your target
falls on
different benchmarks drug four million
drugs or targets Harvey seven I've been
prosecuted by us and others without much
success in the past we've also now
extended cct into the quantum mechanics
little this is made possible because of
the admin and GPU computing in this case
individual specified apportioned angle
through these four atoms prepare the job
for submission method the basis said the
portion angles scanned crammed is put a
button and then this case because of the
length of calculation is running behind
the scenes on the chemical corrosion on
GPUs and those we'd also managed by a
job status movie that tracks among other
things the endpoints the calculation
that you're interested in other jobs
that you've also submitted behind the
scenes nominee traffic right a job
Israeli conceived as a portion scanned
and energy barriers profile as a
function of angle very much in vogue at
the moment is free under perturbation
methods which can capture the world to
combine infinity this case we've license
application for MC pro from for girl
from sinful Abigail and rap and CFO
within PCTs ocean appear interactively
remove it the job is set up these girls
are complicated we have two ligands that
differed no more than by an atom one was
mutated other you can submit it to NC
pro now tcp automates all the steps
necessary to set up the simulation we
need to put in prep generation primer
files etc again this is run you can let
job status who we concede Health
Authority calculation in flanked by all
the files which will come along with it
until very useful this is all done and
move it which is greatly facilitated use
of this particular algorithm throughout
the company
okay i'm going to switch gears again
outside of the structure based world
into the world markfield prompt con
centric data set of chemical Maddox I
found the chemists have a voracious
appetite for data an amazing ability to
keep more conventional information
somehow on their heads but chemists are
also see the value in computers for
either do best which is for recognizing
patterns affecting trends reporting the
odds of historical succession from large
in thousand and all databases they give
an example how we handle this is ekiti
this case the design applications not
move about peek at java based
application regions in writing for for
over a decade increasingly CCTs are used
to run the algorithms and not so its a
linking example is what's in vogue right
now is the concept of national prepares
those you ultimately this technique is
essentially looking at the consequence
of making particular substitution while
holding the rest amount of your
conference we look carefully here this
people there there's a glue moving to a
red of keeping the res amount of
constant joined by this triple bond and
there are some holiday song is the same
thing anything or we're showing the
consequence of making this substitution
in a historical data set for the
property of interest in this case is
Captain kinase activity if they're on
average aggregate how does making this
change behave does it help things are
painful becomes about the same you can
click here and drill you can see all
those examples to see again carried off
with the red dress allowed to be
anything on constant if all such
examples it was the case for this case
the measured in coming and the relative
difference summarized here in this case
is not likely transformational computers
suggesting a replacement for the
consequences but if can afford to make
one what's likely for that will improve
things CCP is also been wired to handle
how the pharmacology models and these
can be very useful in case of phenotypic
screening
for the bioactive molecules neck into
action on loans we may offer test
likelihood that who finds it a battery
of different proteins that even silica
it's also useful for eventually I'm
saying from about the culprit relief for
a compound of showing I those events so
anyway there's a nothing from an
external data for us to train the
physical model he's a 2d model since
losing support vector machine for 650
screen proteins enough confident that
you can generate a positive binding so
cgt means invoking the results from a
cutie cat again there's a query Marla
tool the putative targets if they're
likely for this defining and just for
sanity check we have the reference model
tools in your training set so that you
can expect the similarity about how two
of those other compounds no denying
those targets during the HTS follow-up
process oftentimes Norman often see
whether you can expand the chemical real
estate available to a faculty
practically using similarity surgery
that subject insurgency look like
positive I'll active what we think
money's method called HTF England's
being within the different way namely a
similarity in biological space so let's
examine this tuning matrix one axis
being millions of compounds the other
350 assays that is composite and death
of it the question is given the HPS fit
and it's also been tested elsewhere are
there other compounds that have shown
similar activity vector we will so cct
then we'll compute these vectors and
asked which ones are highly correlated
from results for the correlation for
pushing so he can ask you this following
season to keep find such molecules that
show post pistons were for highly
correlated coefficient and the number of
essays which they had in from now gave
here sometimes you can find out after
molecules that from share obvious
similarity also in the HTS triage step
softly store to see whether the
molecules that show up
active have been known to frequent
bidders or for permits for mysterious
compounds when you train assist from all
around 700 historical essay who scored
likely that something is a repeat
offender that shows up everywhere so the
score to come back he can in this table
for men has a reconfigured swore and
then the most similar molecule in the
training data set and whether that is
known to people figures wrong cop cases
there's not to be and in the round the
case is known to show up after too many
assets in this case 39 essays i
mentioned that ccp plays nice with much
applications are showing one example and
pays a Spotfire tsp of Spotfire duty has
api which we use to of CTP services into
the vfc visualization will select some
molecules then CCP protocol on these
cases it's a third model after scoring
according to our model Basil's come back
and exp it can only messing around or
infant alpha files about formats and
that's different we've discovered the
CCP so powerful so flexible is good not
just for company from chemistry from
computational biology as well this work
would be published a few years ago is
how to interpret in biological terms of
consequences of different
transcriptional changes perhaps on a
team chief experiment by leveraging
information around biological networks
the fairly involved process and Burmese
a map TTT Kendall to others on the
server side what's interesting about
this particular example of causal
evening that not only is it a lie or
problematic project that it runs the
first example for ccg application that
runs within or what in work for
web-based application that is ctp aware
since then public penetrate applications
of rocephin written in the web
applications okay I mention all this
computation where does the complication
up to come from
turns out that we have hpc systems
dedicated for the purpose and so we have
a reasonably sized system dedicated for
chemistry 60 40 50 Millard's 96 GPUs
rocks 40 fair bites of storage and
switch wonderful support for my
engineering degree from MIT now this
system will put in touching about a year
ago which means ready obsolete having
said that we meet on the photographer's
here you see the number of core hours
when the job submitted could be unique
accounts across all these departments of
evangelizing or chemistry the focus this
year's been standing our capacity
performance of our GPS you can with 1640
course we find that the APC is often
purple subscribe this red line use the
16 to 14 realign the number of jobs come
running and green is the number of jobs
queued up waiting for job slots so
clearly as good as the system is is not
enough food hopeful people man so a
couple years ago we start doing some
experiments in Amazon crowded for
justice need ideally just have a new
faculty in CC team for amazon we've been
running these resources when we happen
to keep an end or the internal hardware
configuration aren't a particularly good
fit for the type of algorithm of methods
we asked now here will users can have
you can be aware that their job is
running on Amazon let's see some key and
alder kinda seems worth of starting and
stopping machines at the figure 8 images
and data seven this command has been
driven by there are from the hue
outcomes for Russian dynamics as enjoy
the Renaissance recently as I mentioned
the engine perturbation as well so our
first experiment was to use Amazon Cloud
to nctc services to generate
three-dimensional confirmations for
public databases Inc database important
for the first experiment careful not to
put any proprietary data until i'll be
at
security model worked out this case over
5 million small strings starting funny
and you don't make overtures fool that's
very cloud friendly from the licensing
perspective regenerate three-dimensional
combinations turns out this is perfectly
because at a time our internal grid
would choke buddhist compilations of the
can on amazon you have one too many be
all set that's exactly what happened all
the user ninu of that he or she had five
third million small strings he came back
from javis completely unnatural
compromise in the form of a respected
earning between his handlebar cct in the
town the attacking of that job and then
create the running with the spinning of
the inferences and running a fat
harvesting of the results so that
experiment was a success we wanted to
push the model even further saying well
what if we wanted to use spot instances
for those of you for not familiar with
the spot instances it's like ebay you
can name your own maximum price of one
pay or completely fine an amazon well
Vancouver where will he comes to find a
man for a surge pricing will kick in and
that can vary from our our so that means
in practical terms if the market price
happy to see what will you say and
actually you lose that instance anywhere
any Celtic able to find a spot instance
but the benefits are that the average
prices on spot instance are much lower
than what we've paid on the manual
desert so how's our experience well
there's a lot of good clean from and
this is a particular set of jobs on what
the simulation of coffee compilations
and submitted 507 jobs on spotting
pieces and all about one came back
successful the one that came back is no
fault of Amazon it was that build
complex require just more computer time
so the cost is very favorable for the
whole thing under nine dollars and the
hourly price is mostly minimum for those
particular machine from send from seven
cents per hour there are a few spice in
price but none of them
the one dollar for our level okay so in
other words my last word the downside
was that spot instances returns bands
requires a lot of manual intervention
for starting offer for some reason
beautiful instances did with some time
soon issues with the Florida somewhere
above that requires manual intervention
so that babysitting required for running
a spot instances makes situation curly
suboptimal but having said that the
price point is extremely attractive so
we pushed it even further in this time
we're using for Carter data profile
virtual screening and tons of a real
project on Amazon spotting pieces
decided how many machines are going to
procure this is all the compounds poetry
material available at pfizer so that
after the virtual screen you can follow
up if it's experimentally some
parameters of the in-house Bastion album
use heavy atoms of beautiful bronze 200
ronds that were constrained because we
believe it important for a biologic
including seductive attar 'get good use
run completed in the day and amazingly
total cost of experiment full problems
of screen with three hundred dollars 26
cents per movie four hours of exit
determine exactly so before i wrap up in
the tradition of steve jobs i just want
to show you one last thing and now we
have half of computing with me platform
from collect designed our ecosystem so
last year or two me started developing
applications which run in time iOS ipad
that leverage cct is a particular
application out or finished with is the
so-called sketch pad application so here
there are very commonly accessed
properties and models like the
permeability and solid will relieve
copies like an awful way to fiddle
around count popular CCTs you can pre
certify that interested in by really
drawing structure calling the company
instantaneously all these these features
come back these attributes of your
compound imagine how this changes our
full dynamic logic eating before you
new design idea came up in the context
meaning you have to copy that structured
from the whiteboard and then running the
results between meetings and email
yourself back or safe fulness design now
you can do it for all interactively
real-time design discussion so that
really falls is very rich discussion
work but if questions and the answers
come back all find where design project
happen so with that I want to finish up
and thank everyone in the paper Jensen
provided slide katie's presentacion
principally red box into the leader of a
computational chemistry and my
department and our partners in medicinal
chemistry nit technology partners of
community a senior management advisor
and we're interested finding out more
among contact me my contact information
on the right for that are finishing
people that few Kevin thank you very
much Enoch for that big gulp of
computational science and chem
informatics again my apologies to those
viewing because this is not a live
presentation we're recording this just a
few days before all the actual virtual
symposium goes out live so I'll take a
Liberty of dis asking a few questions
before we wrap up Enoch first I wonder
if you could just quickly just step way
back you've been at pfizer 15 years
where has the implementation of cct
really made the biggest impact on the
company and its drug pipeline I wonder
if you can sort of put a finger on it is
it improving the speed or the go no-go
decision a phrase we hear a lot about is
there one particular area where it
really is excelling and transforming the
whole process of God development single
way that's easy he has facilitated the
drug so because it certainly makes it
more efficient because less time is
being as a medicinal chemist and the
company's on cam
process involves a molecule that could
be made so I guess it's in the design
phase very quickly test certain design
hypothesis for using the battery from
source of tools and methods so you can
quickly find out which avenues and the
most productive as our synthetic
capacity as 1,000 years importance on
design effectiveness and this means
computational techniques which I mean
from here I think it's part of that
solution on how to maintain the output
english and chemistry without
necessarily putting as many compounds
into the process of design synthesis and
testing so I think the sum total of all
these innovations and vision sees I
think you need to collective impact for
chemistry food here you mentioned
medicinal chemistry Enoch fair to say
there's still an important role for
medicinal chemistry because you showed
so many number of very impressive
examples of chemical structures being
iterated a new candidates being
identified almost in real time there's
still a rule of a role for that human
tuition probably i like i said i think
the infrastructure works best if it's in
concert with in the different country
intuition like I said chemistry's have
amazing ability to keep for these
multi-dimensional coffees in their head
but kemas are now also very comfortable
what they say by using computers what
will they do this in track of historical
data these national compares somewhat
non-obvious effects and importantly
because temporary evidence-based backing
up Wolfie will be data improve that that
might be so so I don't think these the
world competition intuition our odds
with each other in fact the avenues
which in that opened up by competition
then allows Tennessee provided intuition
but they follow up in front of the
series and former options
my final question or two part question
is to just quickly talk about your
experience with cloud computing which I
suspect be a theme we hear more about
during the course of the virtual
symposium today one your experience
seems to be primarily with Amazon I'm
curious if you've been tempted to try
any of the other big clouds that we are
bombarded with with the advertisements
for Microsoft Google IBM everybody's
getting on this game now and second
given the success and the the efficiency
of the cloud I'm curious whether is
there even a need to maintain your own
hpc system in house when you had so much
success spinning up jobs into the cloud
at the first part we've had the most
experience at amazon the incantation
chemistry we know we're not alone in Big
Pharma having made some progress with a
particular platform on the genomic side
companies from biology I'm intrigued by
the Google offering particularly that
they have a business around to the
genomics at the moment so i think we'll
use the platform that as the most
features as soon as a sort of passive
and i should also say that the amazon
calendars number of specialty solution
providers vendors that have actually
that can act as a specialist in this
space for company at doesn't have
necessarily the cotton engineering
capability in house but in both areas
i'm very what the different cloud
providers are offering an awful ticket
platform that makes the most sense for
us in a virtual solution is oxygen tubes
if you go far as the digital HPC I think
there's always a need for the on-demand
type calculations we're having like I
said I'm the most attractive price phone
companies five instances as it stands
now is my changing future that required
that the babysitting I can just in
casual friends no way that you can do
that for the vast majority of the jobs
that show you this 800 million
compounding possibly choose between each
month so I think there are special types
of simulations of calculations for which
the cloud makes sense
it's like hardware configuration that
soak up the great regional three
different and more than one of them at a
given time but having that as an outlet
allows them or between transactional
jobs run on the cloud I'm sorry on the
interval grid in the leaf cycle kinds of
chemistry expecting okay you know Kwang
thank you so much we'll leave it that
that's been you know Quang executive
director of computational sciences at
Pfizer getting us off to another great
start here at the scene Ian virtual
symposium which will continue for the
rest of today Thank You Enoch and thank
you all for tuning in and apologize that
this was not a live presentation so we
couldn't take live questions there'll be
more great talks a couple of talks at
the top of the hour and we encourage you
to searching for those as well as a
stroll now to the virtual exhibit hall
where you can interact with our sponsors
and exhibitors and media partners and
there's also a virtual lounge where you
can network with other visitors so here
from around the world and you this year
the virtual symposium a virtual career
fair producing concert with our
colleagues of the american chemical
society where I'm sure there's a lot of
great openings available for you to
peruse we're live on twitter at hashtag
Sen sim 15cms SYM 15 and I hope you
enjoy the rest of the day and the great
talks that we have on time for you so
for my colleagues at caen en el people
behind the scenes who put this broadcast
together thank you very much for
watching on Kevin Davis and enjoy the
rest of the program
you